hi guys I'm Eric Voss and as you can see
behind me our new studio is coming along
nicely and this is a breakdown of the
walking dead season 7 episode 7 sing me
a song and after a few weeks of kind of
slow episodes it's amazing how much
better the show can get by just sticking
close to the comics and getting
characters we actually care about
interesting things to do but in fairness
when I think of The Walking Dead I
definitely think of Tara eating fish
stew now this is a slightly longer
episode so there's a lot to talk about
stuff that you miss stuff from the
comics the hidden meaning and what it
could all be possibly setting up for
next week's midseason finale so let's
get started with the opening images so
the opening shot shows Michonne
returning to these burned mattresses
that the Savior's took from Alexandria
back in episode 4 just to be dicks back
then I speculated that this could be a
reference to the Godfather line go to
the mattresses which means to prepare
for warp given one message I want
Sailaja mad it's all-out war we got an
idea and that's exactly what Michonne is
doing here making a move towards battle
by tracking down the sanctuary and negan
but there's a deeper meaning to these
mattresses they're a symbol for word
domestic life a bed a place of comfort
and safety
now corrupted and ruined by negan so
that idea of the perversion of
domesticity comes up again and again
throughout this episode so I will come
back to it
now Michonne's whistling here is kind of
unsettling for a few reasons for one
this is the farmer in the Dell which is
a children's nursery rhyme and she's
using it to attract walkers for
slaughter but also ever since negan
arrived last season whistling on the
Walking Dead has taken on a new dark
undertone like negan and the Savior's
Michonne is whistling as a device to
learn these targets into a trap and like
negan she takes out her rage on two
scapegoats so she's not just gathering
walkers for a barricade Michonne is also
trying to feel in charge of her own life
by reenacting negan's punishment all
right moving on to this scene with the
two Savior's on the truck we get a tiny
insight into the Savior's war strategy
and point of view they talk about how
fat Joey used demolition sticks and
Daryl's RPG to block off roadways to
herd walkers calling it guerilla warfare
and remember they used these same kinds
of creative roadblocks to catch Rick and
his people last season when the sky says
maybe it takes it down take some out
actually sounds relieved and I think he
might be talking about Rick and that
would actually make sense for these
runners and soldiers to still see
themselves as underdogs because Rick and
his crew have killed dozens of their
people and all these surprise attacks
and they only really got control over
them by blocking roadways and eventually
fear just by killing only a very small
number of them so the point is I think
any war between these two sides will be
way more evenly matched than anyone
thought okay moving on to this statue
that Jesus sees as they approach the
sanctuary it's holding a severed Walker
head much like that angel statue that we
saw in episode three with severed arms
tied to it so once again we're seeing
that idea of the symbol of comfort and
safety being perverted by negan but also
I'm pretty sure this is a statue of
Saint Francis of Assisi he was a
Catholic friar in the Middle Ages who
was famous for miraculously taming a
wild wolf that was terrorizing the
village now before I talked about in the
first episode negan's breaking down a
brick was intended to match the way that
you would bring a dog to heel negan does
a similar thing to Rick's son this
episode whistling when he initially sees
him and scolding his defiant look
same damn stink as your dead I think
this famous wolf tamer is meant to
foreshadow all of that okay moving on to
Carl's balls the entrance at the
sanctuary which is definitely one of the
cooler moments from this stretch in the
comics and pretty much all the dialogue
in the scene is taken directly from
issues 104 and 105 from the comics you
are adorable I'm gonna lie you scare the
[ __ ] out of me that any way to treat our
new guest do not shatter my image of you
but what I was most impressed by was
this wide shot of a sanctuary which
looks almost exactly like it does in the
panel in the comics down to those three
smokestacks the fire escape stairs even
the missing windows in the far left now
remember we didn't see a whole wide shot
of the sanctuary back in episode 3 only
the interior and there's a reason for
that that episode wanted the sanctuary
to feel like a prison cell and
everything feeling claustrophobic with
the shots going from the inside out from
Dwight and Daryl's trapped perspectives
now Carl is looking at it from the
outside in seeing a different side of
the sanctuary this grand palace with a
king in his court and multiple wives
it's more of a show and before I move on
that first Walker head on the pike that
we see with the long hair is a model of
executive producer Greg Nicotero 's head
now moving on inside it's interesting
that negan says this in his Proclamation
saviors have gone out into the world and
fought the dead and come back with some
really good stuff this makes it sound
like saviors is a term that negan only
uses for his soldiers and gatherers not
just anyone who lives in the sanctuary
episode 3 showed us that there is a
strict class structure in the sanctuary
and now we know that the term Savior
refers to this upper privileged class of
soldiers which is exactly how real world
military fascist societies are set up
okay moving on to this scene in
Alexandria and notice what kind word
Rosita uses to describe negan we're not
doing [ __ ] for that go bomb now cabron
is a common Spanish slur kind of like
dumbass but in some usages it's used to
insult a man whose wife is cheating on
him and that makes it a super
appropriate dig for negan considering he
spends his whole episode dealing with
one of his wives cheating on him
basically the only rule in his creepy
polygamist harem that he's super anxious
about but what
you do G that is exactly right
and I'll get back to that sex cult in a
second but I want to talk real quick
about this tense exchange between Rosita
and Spencer we got a produce for them
it's like taxes pay your taxes and leave
me the hell alone
so office talk about taxes is
reminiscent of the early years of the
American Revolution which began as a
revolt over British taxation on the
American colonies and on the American
side there was a divide between two
groups the Patriots who were the
revolutionaries who openly rebelled
against pain what they saw as unfair
taxes and the loyalists who were
American colonists who were still loyal
to the crown and wanted peace even if it
meant paying taxes and I think the
divide between Rosita and Spencer is
mapped over this history with Rosita
being this fiery patriot who's secretly
gathering munitions just like American
revolutionaries did and Spencer as the
loyalist who doesn't want war and while
there's an argument to be made that
Spencer's position is justified this is
an American show and we hate Spencer's
goods despite how gutsy he thinks he
looks in that jacket I am saying guts a
lot moving on now compared to negan's
wives in the comics the show kind of
toned it down like we don't get any
glamour shot of all these women in
lingerie they're covered up a bit more
and the camera cuts away from them I
think this is the show continuing to
soften negan a bit like he's still this
violent psychopathic prick but I don't
think the show wants us to hate him that
much like I hate to say it but I've
almost forgotten about Abraham and Glenn
it's go okay I you know I should have
known that was coming oh god also notice
this moment between negan and Sherri who
is Dwight's former wife I read on you
but I know you there's worse this is a
callback to Sherry's warning - Dwight
back in episode 3 whatever he's done to
you there's more there's always more you
know me works and at the end of the
scene
negan also echos Shari repeating her
line that she said to him - Darryl what
we talked about when you're not here is
none of your business what we talk about
when you're not here there's none of
your business also I don't know if you
got this but when Carl passes Darryl
Darryl whispers get away so Darryl
talking like this definitely negates
that theory that Darryl might have had
his tongue cut out which a lot of people
were thinking was the reason it looked
like he was blinking in Morse code -
Rick in episode 4 either way it seems
like Darryl is capable of whispering
little messages like this if he really
wants to now let's move on to this scene
between Spencer and Gabriel which might
have been my favorite moment this
episode with Gabriel proving he's a
patriot - what you're saying
does it make you a sinner
but it does make you a tremendous [ __ ]
and it is awesome to see Gabriel just
put Spencer in his place but it's not
just an insult it's an actual advice he
tells them it doesn't have to be
permanent and Gabriel knows this better
than anyone
it wasn't too long ago that he was a
tremendous [ __ ] himself be trained Rick
- Spencer's mother Deanna and now that
Gabriel has seen Rick's leadership in
action he respects him becoming a
character that hey we don't hate
so you see Spencer redemption is
possible if you have the guts for it
we'll be on to this private moment with
Carl and negan that again is taken
directly from the comics with negan
mocking Carl's gross eye hole now it's
interesting how Jeffrey Dean Morgan
plays this because Carl crying and negan
apologizing does happen in the comics
but it just never really seems genuine
when comic negan apologizes he always
came off as more of a truly evil
psychopath but here you almost buy it
from Jeffrey Dean Morgan he seems to
actually regret bullying this kid for
his scars that he obviously still feels
super self-conscious about in fact it
almost makes me think that Jeffrey Dean
Morgan could be pulling inspiration from
negan's recently revealed back story in
the comics which I won't spoil here but
it does do a lot to humanize negan and
show why he might care about kids
feelings but then notice how negan being
reunited with Lucille brings back his
more sadistic side and he says this
episode's title I want you to sing me
song
so this was the amazing comics moment
that we were waiting for since we
learned this episode's title and Nic and
terrorizing Carl as he sings a lullaby
that his mom probably sang to him
connects this title in this moment back
to that idea of perversion of
domesticity that I talked about before
so whenever Carl hears the song now
rather than thinking about how his mom
used to tuck him into bed he's gonna
remember negan swinging a bat around his
head negan corrupted this loving memory
with fear okay moving on to another big
scene adapted from the comics when negan
marks mark with an iron to the face and
I'm glad to the show actually went
through was showing this on screen that
way we can imagine it happening to
Dwight and it was great even though the
show cut away from when iron first
touched his face and I know I'm being
probably too nitpicky and definitely too
obsessed with violence but I'm just
saying if this was HBO this would have
looked a lot more like Viserys his
golden ground but also two things I want
to point out about negan here first I
like the way he enters the room banging
Lucille
raylene just like how a judge would bang
a gavel to demand attention in a
courtroom this is after all negan's
version of a trial there's a defendant
witnesses and negan is the judge jury
and executioner and then listen what
negan preaches I wish I could just
ignore the rules and let it slide but I
can't why now this is another line from
the comics but it also works as a
callback to the governor back in season
3 who outlined a similar ideology to
Michonne
you've broken the rules I don't do
anything I am bad anarchy now in both
cases these egomaniacal dictators use a
strict interpretation of the rules to
justify extreme and probably unnecessary
punishment okay moving on dispenser
pulling this Walker out of a tree and
it's kind of a fun mystery how this guy
even died like he's tied up to a tree
stand at Hunter's used to hunt deer and
he has a compound hunting bow so my
guess is this guy was a hunter whose
torso was scratched up by walkers and he
tried to wake them out up in the street
and I have another theory in his
backstory that'll bring up later it's
also interesting that he has this list
of places that he stores food and
supplies written in Latin now this ends
up being a callback that connects
Spencer to his mother Deanna who in
Episode five of last season made plans
for the expansion of Alexandria writing
this Latin phrase for Spencer to read
that translated to someday this pain
will be useful to you which Spencer
recalls at the end of the episode when
he's a pain in the ass class my mom said
that pain would be useful someday and
now Spencer has found a practical use
for his mother's wisdom and he feels
like he's filling in her shoes as a
caretaker of Alexandria but in case
you've been missing some of mine
not-so-subtle jokes I do think the show
is making some moves to foreshadow
Spencer following in his mother
footsteps in other ways too namely her
death like obviously Spencer's face is
covered in blood here just like Deanna's
face when she died last season also
notice that he said that he got this
list from a dead guy with the clamp and
that may be foreshadowing himself as a
guy with big plans who really may just
be a dead man walking okay moving on a
lot of people are wondering what kind of
punishment negan plants are getting Carl
and negan makes up his mind in this
moment when Carl shows his defiance in
another great line from the comics you
jump out the window to save me the
trouble of killing you so negan doesn't
want to kill Carl because breaking
people in is more practical and more fun
for him but is attempts to
right Carl haven't really worked yet and
he knows Carl is more useful as a tool
to get it rich
so if negan were to keep Carl Rick might
be driven to start a war to get him back
negan knows that Carl needs to stay at
home with Rick because Rick is more
useful to him when he has something to
lose there's a few callbacks here to
episode 10 of last season that I really
liked
so Jesus hides on the roof of the truck
again just like in that episode and
notice how Daryl sees them hopping down
right before the truck pulls away
Daryl's like damn how does this guy keep
getting up on trucks but then also
notice how negan flips off Daryl as he
leaves them behind just like how Daryl
flipped off Jesus as they left him
behind in that episode and we don't know
exactly who slipped Daryl denote with a
key taped to it that said go now in this
prison cell like some people are saying
it could be Sheri but I think it's more
likely Jesus because go now is exactly
what he says to Carl right before they
parted ways and Carl didn't listen we
just got to go now
and then real quick we see Michonne
getting a jump on this Savior by using
the same guerilla warfare tactic that
the other savior referenced at the top
of the episode blocking off the roads
and sneaking up on the enemy from the
brush and then let's move on to win
negan returns Carl to Alexandria Olivia
shows negan that the women of Alexandria
aren't anything like the women of the
sanctuary I think it would be enjoyable
just grow your brains out I mean if you
know you're agreeable to me and I gotta
say I'm a little worried about Olivia
for a minor character she's gotten a lot
more screen time this half season and
the minor victory of giving negan the
slap he definitely deserves definitely
feels like a character art coming to an
end and I know I might be reading into
things but as we saw with Denise last
season The Walking Dead loves to kill
off people right after they get a win
now with the title like sing me a song
this episode has been very musical with
Carl's song and negan in Michonne
whistling and this track that plays over
negan touring Rick's house and feeling
carpet for the first time in probably a
while kaapa pissed
this is called bang bang by Janice
Martin it's a 1958 rockabilly song about
lovers making a deal and these lyrics
that focus on trading and the chorus of
bang bang it definitely connects to the
deal at gunpoint that Rick is under
right now all right moving on earlier
Rick and Aaron hopped the gate with this
sign warning them of trouble and now
they find this even better sign now I
love every time the Walking Dead leaves
these markings made by people from
alternate stories that we may never see
it makes the world feel more authentic
and lived in or died in and this Leslie
Williams starting guy sounds exactly
like a lot of Walking Dead fans that I
found online who seem to be actually
preparing for a zombie apocalypse like
as soon as M Dom bees are as I'm taking
my 12-gauge my air 15 my rocket launcher
my two before with nails sticking out of
it and some slim jims swim out the
middle of a lake
do your best Dom bees also there's a
theory that this guy is the same guy
that Spencer found in the tree and that
boat is pulled ashore so maybe he came
to the land at some point but I don't
know if this guy has that many firearms
he probably wouldn't have just gone out
with a simple hunting bow and I don't
think Rick and Aaron were anywhere near
where Spencer was now the closing images
bring us back to Alexandria with this
creepy image of negan threatening to
bury Rick and Carl while holding Judith
and smiling in her face this comes back
to that idea of the perversion of
domesticity and just like he did when he
asked Carl to sing me a song
negan is restating this classic image of
a home a father with his children
drinking lemonade on the porch but we
know that this isn't right that's not
Rick it's an imposter just like
everything he touches negan's presence
here corrupts this domestic image into
something far more sinister okay two
lingering questions one who do you think
has been the most set up to die I mean
let's face it next week is the
mid-season finale and it's titled heart
still beating
perhaps the reference to something negan
says after he kills someone
now I already mentioned Olivia but
Spencer and Rosita both look like
they're about to make a big move like
when they return Alexandria Spencer says
I'm gonna do more than that as in he
intends on ellstein Rick and then Rosita
says he's here as in negan that bullet
is clearly meant for him and this
revolutionary is not thrown away or shot
so we'll see and - do you think negan
could be a good person deep down I know
we saw him iron a guy
face and be super creepy around Olivia
and Judith but Karl killed two of his
guys and all he did was make him sing
apologize for making him cry and then
bring him home to me that doesn't sound
evil it just sounds like a kind of tough
chorus teacher okay thanks for watching
and thanks for bearing with us as our
new studio space comes together so let
me know what you think about this
episode of The Walking Dead in the
comments and check out my breakdowns of
all the Walking Dead episodes this
season
also please hit like and subscribe to
new rockstars and share this video with
all your friends you can also contribute
to us on patreon thanks so much to all
of our current donors you guys are
amazing and if you aren't currently a
patron we would love your support you
can follow me on twitter at EA Voss with
any thoughts or questions you have about
the Walking Dead or you can follow new
rockstars on Twitter at new rockstars
for updates on when our videos are
coming out right thanks for watching bye
[Music]